[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we'll talk to adrian wotznorowski set to
join us on loan from espn
senior nba insider part of espn's
exclusive nba draft coverage this
wednesday
starting at 7 30 eastern woj also
hosting a new three-part narrative
podcast series called the giannis draft
on the events leading up to the 2013 nba
draft
available everywhere podcasts are
streamed
and downloaded and wode's joining us now
loge let me start there
did did the bucks do enough yesterday
to keep giannis long term
i i don't know dan if that question
has been answered yet but they certainly
um
made that team better and that was
uh a directive from ownership from
giannis
they knew they weren't good enough uh
they've been a very very good regular
season team
uh they have not shown that they've been
built for the playoffs they
those are two impactful players and drew
holiday and bogdanovic
uh i would say this about giannis
players come to this crossroad about
staying or going
signing or leaving and generally in my
experience
there are guys who are looking for
reasons to leave and there are guys who
are looking for reasons to stay and i
believed all along giannis has been a
player who has been looking for reasons
to stay you look at his life
and uh how just
i think the things that are important to
him loyalty is a big part of it
and feeling people did right by him
that's a theme throughout
his entire life so i i there certainly
was a lot of enthusiasm
within the bucks last night into this
morning uh they're excited not just that
it makes a team better
but that they've given yama's giving
giannis reasons
uh to want to stay i i think there's a
high confidence level
that they put themselves in position but
he still has to sign that contract
so this podcast is called the giannis
draft it's based on the events leading
up to the 2013 nba draft
when i go back i'm still shocked that
the dallas mavericks didn't end up with
giannis because
donnie nelson is always so good at
finding these players
overseas how did milwaukee did milwaukee
just stumble
into giannis milwaukee did not stumble
into them they had scattered him
extensively jon hamm and jeff waltman
who was their front office at the time
went to see them they were at 15. the
team
that had essentially shut down the draft
process
uh with his agent alex arazis was
atlanta and they had picks going into
draft they ended up with 16 and 17.
they had brought him in for a visit they
snuck him into atlanta right before
he went to new york for the draft but
milwaukee was a spot ahead of them but
dallas is interesting because
donnie nelson has such a history with
international players going back to dirk
and the lithuanian national team and
obviously
driving force and bringing doncic to
dallas he loved giannis
in fact mike procopio who's in the
podcast was in that room their draft
room that night
he remembers nelson comparing giannis
he reminded him of dr j that was the
name he used in the draft room
that night but at the time
mark cuban and the organization they
were determined to get dwight howard in
free agency he was the big free agent
they were trying to create more cap
space and by moving down in the draft
they were able to create more space and
they're another team that in in the
giannis draft and the story
you know lives with the regret of
passing on you know a generational
player in what was
one of the worst drafts in recent
history remember anthony bennett went
number one
in that draft oh boy i saw a tweet this
morning and it says that harden wants
the nets
but kyrie doesn't want james harden
separate fact from fiction here first of
all is harden actively trying to get out
of houston
and is brooklyn the only destination if
that's true
hardin is actively trying to get out of
houston to go to brooklyn
his focus right now is on one team
that's the nets
uh that's not my reporting certainly on
the
kyrie piece i don't have information
that he's not on board
with this i certainly know kevin durant
is very enthusiastic
about it the two teams have
been in contact brooklyn and houston but
i'm told
there hasn't been any real substantive
talk um
about a trade remember the rockets
because hardin has
two years left on his deal they have
some time
on their side they don't have to rush
into anything
different than the anthony davis
situation in new orleans when he was in
the final year of his contract when he
was able to ultimately push the trade to
the lakers
how does this work in brooklyn well
i think the question there's two
questions here
how hellbent is harder on getting
there will he it's easy when you're in
the offseason you're not train camp
you're not playing games
to live with this hanging over you it's
different when your players come to work
every day
you saw that in minnesota with jimmy
butler jimmy made it hard for everybody
to exist
it couldn't go on forever like that i
don't know that that's how james will
approach this
those are different personalities
different people but also from brooklyn
they don't have to have james harden
and i sean marx's track record as an
executive
i don't i i think he's always shown
great restraint
in doing deals the idea of a
you know the kind of deal the previous
regime did
for with the celtics with multiple picks
and multiple pick swaps going out
into infinity almost uh that's not
his style i think there there is the
potential for a restrained offer
for hardin but i don't imagine that
the nets are gonna go at it would go at
it with desperation
they don't have to have them but having
them and the three of them it's
something you've got to look at
and i do think they're going to look at
it and are looking at it
but there's a big difference between
that and getting to a place where you
have a deal
yeah i if i'm the rockets i'm in no
hurry right now i don't know
what are they doing with russell
westbrook
well they're more active in trying to
seek out trades with
westbrook um they're different players
and there's different values on them
around the league right now
you know westbrook right now i'm not
aware of any traction anywhere
on a possible deal i think it's very
likely that both westbrook and hardin
are back
are still on the roster certainly for
the start of training camp in early
december
we're talking to adrian wojnarowski espn
senior nba
insider part of the draft coming up also
has
a new three-part narrative podcast
series called the giannis draft
the events leading up to the 2013 nba
draft
give me what the lakers are doing right
now
well they're certainly excited they were
able to land dennis schroeder
in a deal they're waiting to see what
happens with rajon rondo i think there's
a market for him where he can make more
money
potentially in free agency than is
available for him
um with the lakers
and you know kentavious caldwell pope
is going to be an interesting one
they'll want to keep him i think he's
looking for
a payday with them and i think with
anthony davis it is just a matter of how
long of an extension
or a new deal is he going to do with the
lakers does he get on the same contract
time frame in in a short deal with
lebron or does he go
and extend uh longer than that but but
obviously
davis will be back with la chris paul
deal
um you know i i know he wins i know he's
at a stage in his career of milwaukee i
always felt was going to be a better
landing spot i thought you know to win a
championship maybe but
phoenix almost felt like a lifestyle uh
situation as well give me the logic with
phoenix bringing in chris paul
this is an organization that needs
credibility
they've needed leadership i think they
they really
answered they really started to fill
that leadership
credibility void by hiring monty
williams last year you saw the impact
williams had on that team that's an
organization
i think we've lost woj that's probably
that is an organization
yes it is technically right maybe he's
getting another call ooh
very possible mm-hmm yes mclaughlin
maybe it's a brooklyn area code came in
and just had to
drop it immediately would it be great if
he didn't even say hold on he just goes
remember when we had brian cashman on
the yankees gm
and i said what if george steinbrenner
calls he goes oh i hang up on you
like there was not even any i don't even
know if he says goodbye
i just think it's basically oh i i'm so
take that other call there
but uh fritzy working on getting uh woj
back there
yeah the chris paul situation you know
phoenix probably
looked at what they did in the bubble
where they went 8-0 and went you know we
we can compete with all of these teams
and then you bring in chris paul
all right i mean he wins
but uh what is he 34 35
wode you were just just on the uh the
precipice of telling
something really important about phoenix
i tried to send the other call to
voicemail and i hope you update i
apologize
that wasn't a brooklyn i should know how
to work a phone right now that wasn't a
brooklyn area code calling right
no that was a good western i'll leave it
at that midwestern okay yeah we don't
take those phone calls nobody wants here
from indiana
um so chris paul they think this is
legitimate here with what they can do
you know yeah this is an organization
yeah they need to get in the playoffs
they have been so bad for
so long and rudderless and to have
someone like chris paul
for devin booker for deandre ayton those
are players who have been
a part of a lot of dysfunction there
previous to
monty williams arrival and losing and
bad habits that come from that
chris paul brings just a competitive
spirit a leadership and listen
he's still playing at a very high level
at 35 years old
given that he's got a couple years left
on the deal the fact that robert sarver
is going to pay that contract i think
it's a no-brainer i think it's unique to
phoenix
that's just they need to get into
playoffs they need to show
that they're a real nba organization
again
it's a great nba market it's got great
history in phoenix a great fan base
and they deserve better than what
they've had for a very long time under
starver
i think this for them was a step they
absolutely had to make i thought it was
a great deal for them
i must be in the minority here but i am
sounding the bugle
of what about golden state as a title
contender
and it just feels like when we talk
about the west golden state doesn't
is not in the picture what am i missing
here woj
well i think just the fact that they
were out of sight and out of mind
for a year and durant left and but you
come back and
steph curry and klay thompson and
certainly draymond
and uh andrew wiggins who you kind of
forget
was traded there just prior to the
season shutting down and
they're going to have a chance at the
top of the draft here to get
uh you know one of the elite players in
this draft and that's going to be
somebody either they're going to keep
and try to develop or maybe if they
don't use that player in a trade
on draft night later on that big player
starts banging
the drum to get out of somewhere and
that pick the warriors make
ends up in a larger deal down the road
but uh
yeah listen this warrior team is still
going to be very formidable
in the west like that they're they're
not going away do you have an idea of
who that
name who would want to get out of a
place to end up at golden state is
woach no but listen i think the whole
league is going to wait and see what
happens
with bradley beale he has made it very
clear
he is uh one right now he is in
washington
uh that he is committed to staying there
he signed a short deal last year but
they've got to continue to
improve in washington they've got to
show him that there's a pathway to being
a contender in the east again but beale
is the one everyone's launching i give
tommy shepard and
ted leon says a lot of credit in
washington a year ago
uh when when uh shepard took over you
would have thought beale was on the way
out and he has shown him
um a lot of promise with trying to piece
together
that organization again and so beale has
been very loyal
uh he wants it to work in washington
uh so right now he's not available he
has told them i'm i wanna i wanna be
here now
but that's still gonna be addressed over
the long term every team in the league
uh
would love for badly beetle to be out on
the trade market but but that's not the
case now
what's the wildest rumor you've heard in
the last week or so
[Applause]
oh
uh none come to mind none that are
i think what is going to be really
interesting dan though
is the financial impact of this pandemic
and the loss of revenue
around the league how many teams out
there how many owners
are really going to be willing to spend
and really push it financially here
in the short term you know we talked
about last season being the asterisk
season
yeah i wonder about this year with the
pandemic
and the potential of of the virus
costing teams games just like happens in
baseball or players being out
we took for granted in the bubble
everyone was going to stay healthy
um how many teams actually play 72
regular season games this year how many
key players
are missing in those and you're playing
without fans and all those things
this is the year more than that bubble
championship
where things could get a little out of
whack and as teams are again putting
together
their payrolls and teams there are a lot
of teams
suffering financially in this who you
just may see be
less than competitive less than
aggressive in free agency and around the
draft
owners like steve ballmer the lakers
make a lot of money with that local tv
deal that doesn't go away with no
fans in the arena how does it impact all
these teams as they
put rosters together and try to win this
title
woage good luck with the podcast and of
course the nba draft tomorrow night we
appreciate your time as always
thanks for having me as always dan good
to be with you so adrian wojnarowski
espn senior nba
insider part of the draft coverage
wednesday night it starts at 7 30
eastern on the mother ship
and the podcast called the honest draft
the events leading up to the 2013
nba draft available everywhere
podcasters streamed and
downloaded